TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this would be an episode
of The Developer show,
but I'm on vacation.
However, when I was in
Tokyo, I spent some time
at Cloud Next,
in-person, checking out
everything that was
happening on the ground
so that you could get
a peek at that as well.
Let's check some of that out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
This is Cloud Next, Tokyo.
I'm here to show you
around the conference,
so let's go check it out.
I'm here with Caz at
the Thing Translator.
Caz, what's a thing translator?
SPEAKER: Yeah, Thing
Translator is a web application
[INAUDIBLE] mobile boss.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's a web app.
SPEAKER: Yeah, it's a web app.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's cool.
SPEAKER: So it's so simple.
So anybody can build it.
And you can press a button
to take a picture like this.
So now it's sending the--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's cool.
SPEAKER: --the word or
describes the object,
as well as the
translation to Japanese.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh, so this
is Japanese for flower.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
And just so you can
notice that there
are some other [INAUDIBLE]
so a couple things,
like flower, plant, flower.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I see.
SPEAKER: Very accurate system.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome!
What are some other things
that we can translate?
SPEAKER: Yeah, I can try you.
- [SPEAKING JAPANESE] Clothing.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
SPEAKER: That's true.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I
am wearing clothing.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: This is true.
What about can we
try the ceiling?
SPEAKER: OK.
- [SPEAKING JAPANESE] Ceiling.
SPEAKER: Ceiling.
Yes, it works.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's great.
Now, what tech is this built on?
SPEAKER: So this is
a web application,
and behind the scenes there is a
back end that takes the picture
and sends the
pictures to the vision
API, this using a machine
learning APIs we provide.
So that has the
vision recognition--
the image recognition engine is
based on a deep learning model.
So that's how it works.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Thank you so much, Caz.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And that's
Cloud Next, Tokyo 2017.
If you'd like to catch
some more cool developer
content like this,
please subscribe
to the Google Developer's
YouTube channel
and save the Developer
Show playlist.
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]